non
[Musique]
magas peur quoi la spec un couteau que
tu vas becciu a fait plutôt une chanson
douce quoi ah bah oui j'aime les gens
[Musique]
mais tu m'emm tescou sport de lui avec
balthazar et qu'après on est un peu chez
nous peut leur faire du diabète alors
écoutez j'ai oublié de verrouiller pour
ce contient la chanson
[Musique]
bon allez c'est parti on a déjà annoncé
comme du court je fais des loups tués
alors on est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hum hum
sans défaut
[Musique]
problème on dirait la can tell me you
marry you you
[Musique]
nous sommes une fois
[Applaudissements]
car tous les points
[Musique]
le petit léo est partout
fin de parcours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
ouais connaissent pas mon fils m'a dit
que je dis quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moutier
[Musique]
c'était gaspard et christophe jallet a
existé un boss c'est moche
voilà je suis du der